and the fact of we cannot finding out
that he's been given 350 lashes is quite
shocking honestly after he's been given
12 months already inside
what does car like as a person I mean
we're hearing him described as a 75 year
old grandfather and in what sort of
physical health or what type of man is
he
cause a really nice guy genuinely kind
caring I think this is and he's quite
fragile and I think sending him to a
prison in brick like the Britain remand
prison is it's gonna be overwhelming
yeah do you know I do have to say to you
and I mean understand your concern as a
family friend but so many people are
getting in touch and saying well you
knew what the laws were in the country
what would you say to them and it's
right that he didn't know what the law
was and we all know alcohol and drugs
are really forbidden a really strict but
he's 75 years of age and he's been in
there for 12 months his original
sentence was 12 months in prison not 12
months and 350 Slash's what do you know
about the conditions that he's being
kept in and bremen prison isn't it's not
like prisons here it's not one of the
cleanest places to be in there's no beds
the food's not as good but there are
different sections I think Carl will is
being taken care of very well Danielle
do you know exactly how facing up to all
of this has he been able to talk about
this being in there yeah I think anyone
would be after 12 months and not and he
didn't know for a few months of what was
going to happen and now that they've
changed their thank you it's gonna be
coping very well with that what would
you ask off the British government and
David Cameron in particular to do as
much as they can to help get him out and
if they're not able to get him out
wanted to get rid of the lashes then to
as minimum sentence as a minimum
punishment as they could possibly help
given yeah
many people believe and hopefully
believe that Carl has being used as an
example to other people
hopefully the lashes won't actually
happen and he may well be deported from
Saudi Arabia how much faith do you have
in that I would hope like it's probably
best off if he does get deported and if
he hasn't given the slashes so I do hope
that's all that it is and not a fact
that they're going to give him the
slashes he has been held up as an
example and do you think there are many
many other people like him both side II
and from outside the country as well who
are indulged in an alcohol I'm not sure
about that but I don't think there's
been many cases of Saudis themselves
being arrested for this kind of offence
but there are other offenses that such
as drugs and other kinds of criminal
offenses that have been released in less
than 12 months when they should be a
longer period of time so I think this is
taking a bit too far yeah and he's had
he's had a journey and a half has he not
and his wife has been ill he's been ill
himself to tell us of tell us about the
state of the family and what he's been
through I think the family are in quite
a bit of shock as well finding out that
he's going to be given the slashes
because originally him getting arrested
was quite a bit big shock to all of us
so I don't think they're gonna be able
to cope well with it and his wife I
don't think it's gonna cope well with
her either I mean who would want to
build to hear that her husband's getting
350 slashes